hey this is really funny we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p there's this guy the
eggman he's a liberal Jewish guy up in
in upstate New York who calls into the
show he said he tried watching NASCAR
because he heard you know that's Trump
said the ratings are ratings are down he
wanted to see what it was all about it
doesn't seem like he's gonna be a big
NASCAR fan take a listen to what the egg
man said hey Dave I consider myself
pretty liberal and my wife is like
intellectual liberal way beyond me last
Sunday we watched our first NASCAR race
ever because I learned that there was a
black guy named Bubba Wallace that the
NASCAR driver Ryland some guy had a
black lives matter car and I also
learned that they got rid of the
Confederate flag and banded so I think
their ratings have gone up and I watched
my first race ever now I never will
again it was really stupid but unless I
tried to do it again all these good
polls against Donald Trump and for Biden
are just going to make us more
disappointed if Trump wins yeah I am I
do not want to be so let down again Dave
I really don't need to do I don't suck
give me a break somebody called about
dual side she definitely doesn't listen
to yourself
hey Shalom brother awesome garden I wish
I could show you mine but you know I
can't sell tools
Oklahoma yes of course all good points
by the egg man very very compelling
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about how many
households missed their July first
housing payments it's a huge number
we're going to talk about Portland
approving a cap on how much those food
delivery apps can charge restaurants and
we'll also talk about the latest Corona
meltdown relating to somebody losing
their job all of those stories and much
much more on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
join pakman.com